cette garde de Carson au sud du pays a
été ciblé par une nouvelle frab russe
mardi soir un bombardement mortel alors
que plus d'une centaine de civils
attendaient d'être
évacué c'est une journée difficile sur
place il y avait de nombreux civils
toutes les informations seront fournies
par les services
concernés autre front la ville de Mar
situé dans la région de don au sud-est
du pays le ministre rus de la
affirme que cette localité aurait été
conquise par l'armée russe lundi le
commandant en chef de l'armée
ukrainienne quant à lui qui donne une
conférence de presse pour la première
fois depuis le début de la guerre
indique que l'armée ukrainienne s'est
seulement retirée vers la
périphérie marinkka a résisté pendant
près de 2 ans d'abord rue par rue puis
maison par
maison j nos troupes se trouvent dans sa
partie nord elles ont préparé une ligne
de défense à l'extérieur de la ville
mais je peux dire que cette ville
n'existe
plus si l'armée ukrainienne échoue à
faire reculer les Russes sur le front
elle a frappé mardi un navire russe en
Crimé soupçonné de transporter des
drones iraniens utilisés par Moscou dans
le conflit avec K une attaque confirmée
par le
kremelin